now right now at five high wind warnings
are in effect for several different
areas you can see from our sky cam there
just how much those gusts are taking a
toll on our air quality and visibility
good evening to you thanks for joining
us at five i'm brian loftis and i'm
denise valdez so we begin with live team
coverage here at five joe muller
standing by in one of the hard hit areas
and david charns in studio tracking
outages and video on social media but
first let's get right over to sally
jaramillo with what is going on now
sally yeah brian denise las vegas was
under a dust storm warning that expired
at 4 15 p.m but those dust storm
warnings still remain in place for our
friends in mohave county and san
bernardino county i want to get right
into it where i show you that high wind
warning in full effect that still
lingers all the way into that 3 a.m
start of your tuesday those gusts
peaking up to 50 to 70 miles per hour
we're still tracking the aviation
weather warning all the way to 615 you
can expect delays down at the airport
along with a wind advisory for our
friends on caliente ph they're
definitely going to be tracking those
gusts to peak up to 45 to 55 miles per
hour all of that blue area there right
aside from that an air quality remaining
pretty unhealthy david will bring you
more of that conditions but first also
showing you that northwest inyo county
topped out at 83 miles per hour wind
gusts angel peaks so far 66 mountain
springs with the 50s you can see the
strongest gusts so far have appeared to
be in our higher terrain outside right
now tracking 76 degrees and we want to
show you those south southwest winds
staying 26 miles per hour for the las
vegas valley throughout the night the
wind won't be going anywhere we're still
tracking very strong conditions
temperatures also looking to drop for
tomorrow so we'll be talking more about
the major temperature drop you can
expect along with more wind down the
road and now let's send it over to david
charns with a closer look at what's
happening on social media
yes sally someone tweeted at me earlier
today is this normal and i said no it is
not we normally don't see things looking
like this out here with this dust
warning we're in right now i want to
tell you that the neon museum is closed
tonight if you are planning to head that
way maybe you're in town visiting not a
great afternoon certainly to be outside
so what does that mean when we talk
about
a wind advisory a wind warning this dust
warning that's happening right now that
dust in the air what does that mean so
if you're somebody who is in one of
those sensitive groups you just want to
take it easy maybe not go outside and
exercise right now we're talking about
the elderly people who have
respiratory issues like asthma or
bronchitis and of course if you're like
me who is always rubbing their eyes when
this happens to us every once in a while
when there's so much dust in the air you
want to just keep your doors in your
windows closed let's talk about some
video from earlier today we're going to
show you the time lapse from prim and if
you look to your left to your right
there it is brian loftus indicating he
drove through this earlier today it is
affecting your travel out there
thankfully it looks like we're not going
to see something like this again but
certainly can you can certainly see its
dangerous conditions let's talk about
those power outages right now the good
news is the outages actually seem to be
coming
down at this hour and as we take a look
here in southern nevada we're just at
about 188 customers without power so
that's pretty much nothing we see some
mild some sporadic outages here in the
henderson area over on mount charleston
where we tend to see these outages when
we get these wind events all right brian
denise back over to you all right i do
want to point out i was going the speed
limit there david driving back from
disneyland
well the west side of the valley getting
hit by some of the strongest winds that
david and sally have been referencing
joe moeller continuing our team coverage
from the 215 and summerlin parkway and
joe we can tell just by your shirt
moving around it's still pretty blustery
out there
yeah definitely over the past hour the
wind has definitely picked up when the
air quality seems to have gotten much
worse i'll give you a live look here if
you're familiar with this area summerlin
parkway and the 215. if you're going
east on summerlin parkway you can
usually see the entire valley you can
see the strip but you can just see how
much dirt is in the air right now and if
we pan over the 215 just north of red
rock just about an hour ago you can see
red rock casino from this point but you
can't even see that but this is really
impacting
the conditions for drivers you can see
the 215 here we spoke to some truck
drivers earlier who were preparing for
this win
as the wind picks up the concerns for
truck drivers begin from dust causing
low visibility to worries of trailers
flipping drivers at this truck stop on
blue diamond in the 15 knew the wind was
coming monty fanell was on his way to
southern california he has been tracking
the warnings on an app on its phone i'm
just trying to get there as safely as
possible so i don't have more delays if
a truck load isn't heavy enough some
truck drivers will pull over if
conditions get bad enough to avoid a
flip other than a snow storm fennel says
the wind creates some of the most
unfavorable driving conditions but a big
concern is other drivers especially if
winds are high
slow down don't maneuver as quickly
don't jerk the steering wheel
back out here live i want to give people
another look at this area if you're
familiar with it you know you can see
these hills
to the west of summerlin west usually we
can see how much dust is in the air we
just heard that truck driver take it
slow another quick look for driving
conditions here summerlin parkway you
can see just how much dirt especially if
we look eastbound here you can see the
air quality is just not the best right
now so tips out there slow down take it
easy and if you don't have to be on the
road it might be a good idea to stay
home i'll send it back to you in the
studio